live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
movie moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
simple of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing
relationships dr john deloney number one
best-selling author host of the dr john
deloney's show
is my cult ramsey personalities my
co-host today
big day today around ramsey hundreds of
folks out here in our lobby watching
this happen if you didn't notice we just
changed the intro
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from
the pods moving and storage studio we
have a new sponsor
for the studio and an incredible group
of people they are they're incredible
it's uh
pretty cool and you know one of the
beauties of the the life that i get to
lead is i get to meet
behind the scenes people that have done
huge things and
you know people that like i would wanted
to have me when i was a kid if i could
meet that guy you know and these pods
the pods leadership team are those kind
of people and we've known them for a
long time and we've known how well this
company operates and how their values
are because we don't just you know put
the ramsey show or the ramsey name of
the ramsey logo alongside anybody who
writes us a check
we're not that easy a girl i'm just
saying so i mean we really we really uh
we we want to align ourselves with
companies that think the way we do all
the way through
and that way we know that when we tell
you guys out there that something's
ramsay trusted
that you can trust
what we said that we didn't just we're
not sellouts right you know and so lots
and lots of diligence gone into this
we're really really careful and uh we
wondered is there a connection to a
moving and storage company
and uh well we've endorsed real estate
agents for decades right i mean i don't
know maybe millions of transactions
certainly hundreds of thousands of
transactions with ramsey real estate
elps and uh if you sold your house i
reckon you needed to move right
and both into and out of right exactly
you got it there there's a lot going on
there right and so um
and you need a company that you work
with moving man
moving companies
some of them are like yeah it's tough
man it's like i mean some of them are
good but some of them are like the whole
idea is it to start with having to
uproot myself and my stuff i have my
little nest made and i gotta be
disorganized and i'm ocd i can't stand
that you kind of live in that world but
that drives me nuts me too and so you
know then you get a company that like
sort of does what they're supposed to
say no no no we're not doing this we're
not doing this we're not doing this we
need a company that that you can work
with that cares about you cares about
your stuff shows up when they're
supposed to
you know it's and we searched high and
low and then we got connected with these
guys and we're really excited about it
i've i have sitting behind closed doors
listening to the conversations and
walking through this this product and
what this
works on the product just the service
this group
uh offers i think of myself my wife and
two little kids trying to get from point
a to point b
and hey we're gonna move on this day and
then this happens and then we can't move
on that
this company's thought through
everything they thought through
everything and they make it accessible
for a knucklehead like me to actually
get out of my home and stay married and
still have a like not have carried my
kids you can kill each other moving
today you can kill them to death
exactly that'll do it yeah yeah so it's
it's it's just man it's so cool just to
see the stuff and think man so 23
million people will move each year in
the u.s one in five ramsey listeners
tell us
that they plan to move in the next year
and pods has been trusted with over six
million moves they're the industry
leader in container and container moving
and storage
you can pack store move your container
move do it on your terms so they bring
it to your driveway set it there they'll
leave there as long as you want right
pick it up if you your closing gets
messed up they can store it for you uh
and deliver it later
or they can pick it up and take it
straight to the new house and all that's
the flexibility and nowadays
everything's so chaotic well it changes
on the fly and so you just pick up the
phone and go ah we're not going to
really be dropping this thing and uh
such a city yet we've got to get that
deal fell through but we're going to
have to put it in storage because we got
to get out of the other house we're in
corporate housing for a little bit and
our stuff is in storage and you don't
have to move it six times in and out
unpack it pack it back up that's the
part that
breaks up couples right it's the breaks
of people's brains oh man
yeah and the the drivers
that drive the containers they all work
for
the company like their team members
right that's the part that is is they're
not like joe just get the thing out
there and throw it around no i mean you
hire this company who then outsources it
to this guy yeah then halfway he
outsources the rest of it
you
yeah this is a guy matter of fact the
guy that brought we've got a pod outside
and the guy that brought it lives over
my old neighborhood in antioch yeah and
so me and will been hanging out out
there and uh great guy he's the driver
that brought it brought the one we got
one sitting outside and as soon as i got
here this morning the team started
asking are we moving
that's right
no wouldn't all fit in one pod hun i'm
just telling you but yeah so uh really
really good stuff and the cool thing i
saw this video they started talking to
me about this when they set the thing
down if you pick it up and it slants you
know all your crap slides to the back
and crashes into itself and breaks right
yeah they've got these like super
computer things
it's called a podzilla
and so it slides it grabs it and keeps
it level picks it up sets it on the
truck podzilla that's a great name
that's if anyone named a podzilla would
be dave ramsey well i mean this is like
you know
yes boys with
trucks you know so yeah you put the
podzilla it keeps it level the whole
time and then and when they set it off
on the other driveway if you're like in
tennessee and you have a hill there's
levelers and they can keep the thing
it doesn't ever slide all your junk to
the back are your precious items i'm
sorry not your junk your your precious
items to the back you don't want to
throw your precious items to the back so
they're hanging out with us today uh we
got hundreds of people in the lobby
today and you people in the lobby
there's hats and there's uh all kinds of
good swag stuff good drink glasses and
or what do you call it tumblers tumblers
thank you but like a hot hot thing so
that's good yeah check them out we got
good pods moving in storage and with our
headsets on we really can't wear these
proper hillbilly ways sideways or cool
dude way or i'm you can't you kick the
brim up that's i'm friendly
that's not what that means put this down
you put this down it means i i i don't
think i'm friendly right so we got a
country star we can't do well yeah
there's that or wanna be one that's
exactly right
anyway you guys get the swag out there
it's out there for you guys we want you
to enjoy it um and make sure there's
none left for the people tomorrow
just don't don't leave anything for the
people tomorrow i'm telling you and hey
let's reiterate this as as an employee
coming in here i had to turn over mris
and x-rays like that's how thorough you
vetted me
this company was super our eyes we won't
know if you had any back problems that's
exactly right you didn't really but you
you were very thorough and when it comes
to vetting a partner like you said it's
not a sign up sheet and it's not a just
writing a check this is a company that's
thought through
how can we take care of people and then
behind closed doors they're great human
beings yeah and that's that's to me is
the winning combo and can i trust you
and we actually do what you say talks
about the anointing drops from the beard
if the leadership team sucks but the
company's good it ain't gonna be long
for the company side that's right
and so you know and even if the
company's got issues if you got a good
leadership team they'll fix the issues
right so uh you know we do we have
issues around here sometimes but we fix
them right you know and so we've even
talked to some of our team members that
have used pods moving in storage they
loved it the new pods moving and storage
studio it's not a new studio same old
studio but it's now newly named
pods moving in storage ramsey studio
welcome to the gang guys welcome into
the family boys and girls
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
19 minutes after the hour dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today we are newly broadcasting from the
pods moving and storage studio got a
little pod up here behind us john in the
bookshelf so those of you watching on
youtube you can see our little miniature
pod there's a full-size one outside hey
we know a lot of you are scared right
now i was just taping a
spot for fox news just a few minutes ago
and the number 20 million people getting
ready to have their electricity cut off
that's pretty scary wow that's pretty
scary and if you feel like you're
drowning and you feel like you're
terrified and you don't have enough to
take care of your family you don't have
to live in fear i've been there i know
how it feels and finally at the bottom
of that my fear changed to anger and i
said i've had it i've had it i'm not
living like this
you can't keep doing the same thing over
and over and expect a different result
something's got to change
and maybe it's time to try financial
peace university you've been thinking
about it somebody's been telling you
about it you've been putting it off and
maybe it's time to go all in on the
ramsey way the course will teach you our
step-by-step plan to get out of debt
save for emergencies build wealth be
outrageously generous it's worked for
almost 10 million people have been
through this class right now we're
offering at the lowest price we ever
have
stop living in fear go to
slash
ramseysolutions.com
ramsay solutions dot com slash
fpu
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five sarah is in
fresno california hi sarah welcome to
the ramsey show
hey
hey what's up
okay hi um how are you two doing today
great how can we help
okay so in september i applied for a
mortgage fair forbearance and
initially i did not tell my husband and
it went on until about this past july
i i woke up in the middle of night with
anxiety and god was pushing me to tell
him and so
i talked to him about it we have not
combined our incomes um
and i'm just i'm just overwhelmed and
don't know what to do at this point
what about
him
made you feel like the best path forward
for your safety was to lie to him
um
honestly i just didn't want him to get
mad and i didn't want him to know
about my spending and i was going to
only let it go on for about a month or
two so this this wasn't you being scared
of of an abusive guy or a frightening
guy it was you hiding from him
yes shame
shame yes
um at the end of november my stepson
passed away so i just his son and so i
just let it go because it was a
stressful time yeah okay so the house
that you and your husband live in you're
supposed to be financially responsible
for by yourself
um
well well we
i i pay the mortgage and he pays the
other
other bills
but or in this case you don't pay the
money don't pay the money
are you not paying because you don't
have any money or you're not paying
because you spend out of control you
don't have and you're not saving right
yes that's it i spend out of control and
i'm not saving anything
and we have a lot of debt and
five years we'll marry
six six years next month
so how far behind are you on the
mortgage now
um about sixteen thousand dollars um the
forbearance is over and the past due has
been added to the end of my term
so i have to start remaking payments and
so you're current you're current right
now
yes the 16 got laid on the back
yes
so he knows all of this
yes i i discussed it with him and i've
been asking if we could just combine our
incomes and do a budget and we talked
about all of our expenses but
i have the every dollar app and i just i
just want to be able to do everything
with him
and it's just hard
it's just hard getting him to sit down
with me and do a budget
but hold on
you've been cheating on him for a year
yeah right and so i i can imagine his
trepidation to sit down at the table
with you
and be like oh okay it's all cool you
see what i'm saying
he's gonna need some time to heal man
you've been lying to him
and he's especially through a trauma
right and so i have you you said we
discussed it that's usually a word for
we passed along information back and
forth
have you sat down and said i wronged you
and i'm sorry
no i haven't
okay in in our world in the financial
world the phrase we use for this is
financial infidelity
yeah okay that's why john said you
cheated on him because it's a breach of
trust
similar to
not the same but similar to
sexual infidelity
um and so this is what you're dealing
with this is a pretty serious
schism
canyon
scar
in euros relationship that we've got to
work to heal
okay
yes and so um
uh uh
now
i don't know john you can throw this out
i i don't expect him and you don't
either i don't think anybody in this
discussion expects him to trust you
instantly blindly that's right there's
no reason to he'd be nuts if he did yeah
that would be weird okay but can we
rebuild communication and can we rebuild
trust yes we can and the best way to do
that is to work on your money together
and both of you are watching everything
the other one does because we are doing
this together all of his spending all of
your spending all of the bills are all
accessible to both of you because we are
working our house our plan together and
so get it you know
um maybe the way to work on it is this
um
uh i'm with john you start maybe with an
apology to lead the conversation this
time hey
i missed you over i didn't i didn't want
to i was i did it out of shame but it
doesn't matter it's just the same thing
it's uh it's a breach of trust and i'm
really sorry
now i'm scared i'm scared about two
things
number one i'm scared because i don't
want to do this by myself anymore i need
some help
i want to be i want to be engaged i want
to be accountable i want everybody to
know what's going on and so i need your
help and i'm scared that if we're not
working together and you're not seeing
everything it's going to be hard for you
to rebuild trust
so if we were to work together it would
be you helping me
and simultaneously
you
get to trust me over time because you
see us doing this together the right way
this money stuff
how's that conversation go
a lot better than it had in the past
because i want you to catch the magic of
what dave just told you that
conversation is entirely about you
you're not sitting down across the table
saying hey you need to be doing this
stuff for me it's not that it's you
saying i screwed up i'm scared will you
help me will you walk with me
and i want to rebuild trust and a good
way to do that is for you to see
everything
while we're doing it together
yeah that would be amazing yeah i i know
i take i take responsibility
because it's my responsibility but you
know we're not here to shame you no it's
just
the beauty of a conversation like that
is that you don't have to throw any
grenades on his side of the table you
can hold them all in your hands
and uh that takes you to some really
cool places
so um i i i think you got a shot at this
if that kind of a conversation does not
bring the two of you to start working on
your money together you need marriage
counseling
okay
and here's one thing i want you to try
okay you may need it anyway yeah i i
think you're going to anyway because
you've been through a trauma he lost his
son right y'all been through a lot
yeah um and he found out he might be
losing his home right that's been a
scary season he's been through
um here's what i want you to do
personally
i want you to go to home depot or lowe's
or something and i want you to buy a
cinderblock
and i want you to put a piece of duct
tape on it that just says i lied about
my money
to the man that i love
and i want you to carry it around for 15
or 20 minutes at your house and feel how
heavy that sucker is and your shoulders
are gonna get heavy
and your hands are gonna hurt and then i
want you to take it into the backyard
set it down rip that duct tape off of it
and never pick that shame up again fair
yes because if every time you sit down
to talk about budget that shame comes
back up you're gonna get feisty again
you're gonna blame you're gonna poke
you're gonna hide and we need that shame
to be away and secrets man that that's
the that's the gasoline for shane there
are secrets when i filed bankruptcy and
i was 28 it was my fault i was stupid
i had to do that exact exercise i had to
set it down and go
i did something stupid i am not stupid
there you go
it's not an identity thing this is the
ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage casey
and elise are with us it is it is elise
correct good welcome welcome where do
you guys live des moines iowa cool cool
well good to have you guys all right
casey what'd you do to the foot
broke it and doing yard work here about
a week and a half ago anything to get
out of yard work yeah i wanted her to
pack the van before we left
hey you've got to come up with a better
story man
that you kung fu chasing a bear
was chasing a bear away from my children
oh my gosh well welcome guys y'all live
where do you live uh west des moines so
just west of on the west side of des
moines iowa good deal how much debt have
you paid off we paid off two hundred
sixty thousand dollars forty seven
hundred two hundred sixty thousand forty
seven dollars and eighty six cents love
it how long did this take ten years in
one month all right and your range of
income during that time we started
around seventy thousand we peaked in
2019 about a hundred ninety and then we
went down to about 150 for a couple
years
and this year we're projecting to be
north of 300. whoa
nice jump okay
pretty cool what do y'all do for a
living i'm a veterinary technician in
surgery
and i own my own uh mep mechanical
electrical plumbing engineering
consulting firm oh and it's doing well
it's just doing really well right now
the little construction boom well way to
go okay i'm guessing 260 000 over 10
years maybe you paid off your house yes
sir i'm looking at weird people
i love it how old are you weird people
36 and i just turned 35 last weekend 36
and 35 and what's this house worth
about three and a quarter good deal how
much in your uh retirement savings we're
hunting 120 130 right now okay so you're
bumping a half million dollar net worth
already on the personal side and you
throw the business in there's a bit more
there so oh yeah you might be over a
million uh we're there yeah i love it
baby steps millionaires
i love it way to go you two 35 year old
millionaires i like talking to these
with no rent yeah
not a payment in the stinking world way
to go all right what's put you on this
ramsey way 10 years ago
so i was on a trip to chicago for a
convention and kelly that's sitting over
here and i were in the car together for
what six seven hours and i was
complaining about my credit card company
not increasing my limit for me
and he had just gotten married and taken
financial peace and
was like hey have you heard of dave
ramsey before and i was like well i
think i've heard of him on the am radio
a couple of times but so we listened to
a couple debt free screams on the way to
chicago the way back we listened to
podcasts from you all the way back i was
fired up
and it was like hey we got to do this
he came home was telling me about it i'm
a natural saver so i was like yeah i'm
on board with this yeah that makes sense
where you been
i mean i was ready to do this before
took some goober on the radio to get you
to do it yeah way to go guys all right
so you sit down what happened after you
get home you both say we're in
we sat down and
i might be a little bit of a nerd i had
every dollar we'd spend for the last
seven years in spreadsheets but i'd
never actually put it together to see
how much we were spending so we put our
budget together she
made some cash envelopes with old
t-shirts she sews them together oh that
was after fpu that's right we want to
take fpu and we're like we couldn't come
up with a hundred bucks
we were making almost about seventy
thousand dollars and we couldn't come up
with a hundred dollars to buy the class
and so kelly and his wife purchased the
class for us oh my
yeah wow that's cool paying it forward
yeah yep yeah and now you're
millionaires and now we're millionaires
way to go kelly touchdown yeah i like it
man if you weren't tripping over mowers
in the yard you would be
cylinders man
[Laughter]
i kept waiting for you to say my my
company does um mechanical plumbing
electric and uh landscaping but you left
that one out yeah
what was your biggest fight in 10 years
what was the hardest thing for you all
to work through uh we sold the cars in
2013.
yeah that was a hard one when i told her
i was selling my tea here at tl she
teared up she knew how much i love that
car
and
it was at that point that i was just i
was done i was like we need to get rid
of this dead um she ah she lost her job
what
we were halfway through the class maybe
a month and a half in and this was back
when it was 13 weeks
and that was a huge wake-up call for us
because i realized that if i lost my job
we were already in trouble with her
losing her job but i was 70 of our
income if we lost my income
it was bankruptcy that's what we were
looking at and so we kicked it pretty
hard and uh sold the cars and that was a
total god situation
um got you in a place where all you had
left was the house yeah we cleared 30
000 in debt that month that we sold the
cars
i sold my tl for six thousand dollars
more than i owed on it i was planning to
spend five or six thousand dollars in
another car
and and went looked a few cars that
weekend i paid thirty two hundred
dollars for two camrys and we that then
had covered the gap on her uh her car
her lexus rx 350 that we bought right
after i bought my tl
and
her parents ended up buying it from us
paying us three thousand dollars more
than the dealership was going to ah
which is a better deal for them yeah
yeah good and then i paid off my last
student loan a month and a half later or
baby step two that finished off baby
step two which was 91 grand and how did
you stay with it 10 years though we
coordinated over 12 classes oh wow wow
12 that we can think of so
yeah okay at least he gave you financial
peace university how many have you given
away
oh i
at least five or ten yeah yeah i figured
that hundred dollars cost you 500. yeah
it was a regular wedding gift
some other people as well so yeah that's
what happens to me too i love that how
has this strengthened your marriage over
the last decade
yeah we're weight and stronger together
bound together tighter
lines of communication opened up when we
started it
and we don't have that stress anymore
and there's still you know things we got
to figure out in the budget especially
you know grocery prices going up as they
are and we have three kids the
medical bill get medical bills yeah yeah
so
yeah but uh seriously how does it feel
to not have a house payment
unbelievable uh opens up the doors that
we're able to do some really fun things
i've got a cousin that's going through a
really rough situation
right recently becomes a single mom of
five with no income
and we just talked to her on the way
down we were able to send her a really
nice birthday present yeah make sure
those kids eat yeah good man good good
couple
well done you too and that's why we do
this right you live like no one else so
later you can live and give
like no one else
touchdown baby touchdown i love you guys
your heroes man you're awesome very very
very cool great job okay you taught all
these classes you did it you're 35 years
old your baby steps millionaires you
paid off your house when someone says
how do you get out of debt what do you
tell them the key is
you gotta have the why you gotta have
the perseverance uh to push you through
because it's exciting at first but you
gotta you gotta get through that
marathon it's not exciting a second
third fourth or fifth or third
home is exciting first is exciting
second third not exciting pain in the
butt yeah so yeah you got to persevere
and the only thing that does that's your
why what did you guys define as your why
why you're doing this
for me oh go ahead no you're fine but
it's helping those single moms those
widows those people that really need
that step up the hand up um
and you know be able to teach them
christ's love yeah and minister to
people in a way that a lot of people
can't because they're so leveraged yeah
okay
all right let's bring the kiddos up i
want to meet them we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you since you are
one i'm my latest number one best seller
we've got a financial peace university
membership for a year another one you
can give away that's perfect and i um a
total money makeover book for you to
give away as well all right what are the
kiddos names and ages we have emilia
that's eight jeremiah is five and james
is nine months all right go james love
it good stuff
good stuff well you guys changed your
family tree you took control of your
life
and you went from making 70 000 to
making 300 through the journey 100 dead
free and become baby steps millionaires
house and everything you're impressive
so proud of you thank you very very well
done good stuff good stuff all right
casey and elise des moines iowa 260 000
paid off in 10 years in one month making
70 to 300 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two one
[Applause]
how fun is that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five danny's in dodge city
kansas
hey danny how are you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well great um i was calling to find out
last year i sold some property that i
had had for
around four years in colorado and
by the time expenses and everything were
paid out and
i walked away and put into a trust like
2.5 million dollars i hate it when that
happens
and at the time
the cpa and the lawyer that set up the
trust for me the cpa
was talking to me about like annuities
and all that and i just didn't at the
time think last year was a great time
to invest
invest it so it's just been in the bank
and now i'm starting you know i'm 51
years old starting to wonder is it time
to put that to work for me through some
passive income or something and
what other investments wonder what other
investments do you have me and my wife
each have roth
with about 300 000 in them a piece
i have some farm ground that's worth a
half million dollars it's paid off we
have our house we owe
30 000 on
um well you've done really well
congratulations yes i've done well and
this is
money that you know it's kind of just a
windfall from that
investment well let's just think about
some basics for a second okay
if two and a half million dollars owns
almost nothing which is what it's
earning right now
or if it own if it earned 10 percent
that'd be 250 000
so every year it sits there earning
nothing you're missing out on 250 000
dollars
so we need to do something with it to be
wise right okay
now and i just didn't know last year
where the market was heading out i don't
care where the market is i don't care
where the market's headed on the short
term
uh all i care about long term because
you're not going to jump in and jump out
and jump in and jump out i'm not going
to teach you a day trade or buy bitcoin
or some kind of bull crap like that i'm
going to teach you to invest long term
that's what i do right now i buy two
things danny you can buy whatever you
want to buy but i buy two things both of
which make me more than a ten percent
rate of return on average some years not
some years a lot more but an average of
over ten
one is i buy a series of good growth
stock mutual funds
spreading my investments in growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international
the second thing i buy is i buy real
estate that i pay cash for that is
income producing real estate
um you've had pretty good luck with real
estate so you may want to consider some
of each
but even if you went heavy real estate i
wouldn't be mad at you for that it's up
to you which one do you want to do but
you need to put this in you know go buy
you a nice little
office warehouse or a strip center or an
office building or something
that's producing
you know a couple hundred thousand
dollars a year for your
you know your two million dollar
investment here uh that kind of a thing
and or maybe you do a million dollar in
real estate you do a million and a half
in mutual funds i don't care but we
never do investing for the short term
that's not investing that's speculating
right we do long term you know when you
bought that farm ground you didn't buy
it for what it'd do the next week or or
two years later you bought it for what
it'd be long term right that's an
investment mindset investing is a
mindset speculating is a mindset so i
you know get with a good real estate
agent pick you out some income producing
property or jump on ramseysolutions.com
click on smart vester pro
and um
sit down with one of the people that we
trust in the smart investor world that
we're not in that business but they can
help you with some mutual funds
and do some of each or all in one or all
in the other i don't care but leaving it
just sit there no an annuity no and
don't use your cpa
for financial advice they're not good at
it is there a clock on that money dave
before it like with capital gains if
he's already he already paid it he's
already paid it okay it's done okay yeah
he did that's done sticking a trust
doesn't hide it from capital gains okay
so um but john i think the important
thing regardless of if it's uh 2.5
million or if it's uh
100 000 you know in your 401k
you need to stop and think about what
you're not getting
by sitting there yeah there's some great
psychological research on
we underestimate what we don't get by
sitting on the sidelines we're so
terrified to risk we're so terrified to
put stuff out there we calculate that
and we over inflate that but we under
inflate what we miss by sitting on the
sidelines and i think it's the same part
of our brain that
i read one thing that said if you lose
10
a share on stock you have to make fifty
dollars
to get a share level of feeling to level
the feeling out because ten dollars does
more damage to your psychology than a
fifty dollar gain does
five to one yeah to your to your uh just
to your psychology it damn you know and
so it's the same thing on that but what
we're talking about here is financial
people call it opportunity cost yes you
have the opportunity to do this with it
and i we used to do this in an old
financial peace university less than a
thousand years ago we don't do any more
i rolled a mercedes out onto the ta out
onto the
uh thing we disconnected the battery we
were inside this church doing the video
shoot right but we rolled this mercedes
out and we said okay if you put a
hundred thousand dollars in this
in ten years
you'll have nothing right
you know or virtually nothing right if
you put a hundred thousand dollars
in a mutual fund in ten years here's
what you'll have and it's like a million
bucks right and so
so even even if the market was half of
that just by parking it you're losing
out on six figures yeah so you're you
know
if you put it in the wrong thing and it
goes down
like a car or you consume it yeah
or you do nothing or sits making you
know a quarter of a percent of savings
account you're missing
the upside so it's the by putting the
money in the mercedes you miss the
opportunity to having invested and it's
okay to buy a mercedes of course i've
got one yeah there's nothing evil about
that but you need to think about when
you're doing it
that money is no longer working
yes it's now lazy money
it's it's it's depreciation or if it's
going down in value it's welfare money
right i mean it's going the wrong way
right right but it you know what you
want is you got to think about if that
money was working
breaking a sweat what would it do and
the thing about money is it works 24 7.
it never gets sick
it never quits it never gets mad at
covid it never it never has a hissy fit
it doesn't think it's a snowflake it
just works all the time it's best
employee you'll ever have it just works
and works and works and works and works
but you got to put it to work
but it because it doesn't work i've nev
i'm thinking about this out loud in real
time i i've never thought of it
i'm guessing that everybody needs to
know where they fall on that risk
continuum because i identify with that
last caller if i got a windfall my my
head i would say i don't know what to do
i'll stick it somewhere and i'd look up
in 10 years and still be there but i can
also imagine other people
would rush to just start wheeling and
dealing it and they're going to end up
losing some of it so that's the other
end you got to know where you are
so uh you know being paralysis of the
analysis
is is not good yeah and being rash and
gambling is not good right but you have
to take enough risk to not miss out on
what life has well it's almost this is
why you and i jumped out of an airplane
the other day you know you got you gotta
jump you gotta you know you gotta take
enough risks to live that's right and
also it's good to have a former navy
seal strapped to your back so you're
probably gonna like that's helpful
you're probably gonna land right um that
yeah that's that's really good and
heading into that having a plan man
having a plan is everything i think
about all the training guys in the
military will do so that when they hit a
chaotic situation they it just goes to
rote i'm going to do this and then this
and then this than this
muscle memory right so when i autopilot
if i live with the little stuff when i
get a 2.5 million dollar win follower 25
000 or whatever that is i i already have
the game plan for what that's gonna do
but that's we're gonna do that money and
we were just hanging with some seal guys
the other day and you know they were
telling us the same thing it's not
really when you hit chaos or if you hit
chaos it's just when it will that's
right and so if you've done the training
your brain is ready you're going to
autopilot when stuff goes sideways
that's right um not exactly the way they
said it but yeah when things go sideways
right and so yeah that's what separates
folks right i'm trying but it's the same
thing's true with money okay so
yes you should not throw money around in
something just because somebody said to
you need to understand what you put the
money in that may take a hot minute
but it doesn't take five years right and
it doesn't take you know like we you
know i took a call in the early days of
the show this guy had like he had like
20 000 bucks
in rolls and buried in his backyard in a
coffee can
and he's like so what do you think of
that
and i said i think you're losing two
thousand dollars a year how long has it
been back there ten years i said you've
lost more than the money in the can and
you ought to go check the money in the
can because paper money doesn't do real
well in moisture it might be gone by now
so you know you you do have risk buddy
it's called rust and worms yeah and and
neighbors with a
you know a metal detector
i noticed back here somewhere i saw him
burying it
this is the ramsey show
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving in storage studio it's the ramsey
show where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual real amazing
relationships dr john deloney number one
best-selling author of the book own your
past change your future and host to the
dr john deloney show is my co-host today
the phone number will talk about your
life and your money right in front of
you the phone number's triple eight
eight two five five
two two five jack is on the line jack is
in jacksonville florida hi jack how are
you
hey how's it going david john thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up
um yeah so i recently had a career
change um in my previous employer i
vested about 7 800 privately held stock
options to purchase um i've asked for
them as an offer purchase center like a
dollar a share like i said they are
privately held
and so yeah just looking for some advice
as to whether we should purchase any or
not i just got married in february with
my life
and
we don't have any debt we have about 10
grand in our emergency savings
and we also have a sizable announcement
for a down payment for a home we're
currently renting um and yeah just like
want to know what the best option would
be moving forward
okay um the the way i answer questions
on this show jack after 30 years of
doing this is if knowing what i know
if i woke up in your shoes with what i
do and that's the way i look at it okay
you're newly married you got 10 grand
you got a house down payment
and these are privately held shares
uh do i invest in them okay
everything in your life sounds normal
except that
that kind of stands out over here is
weird you know yeah yeah
that's an investment you would make if
you had a million dollars you'd been
married 40 years
whatever and if you wanted to have some
play money
uh you would goof around with that okay
so
a couple of issues i would have with it
if i were in your shoes is number one
it's single stocks uh so you've got all
of this money basically all of your
investment money at this point
tied up in a single company
so as it goes so goes your entire
portfolio so that's called risk because
you're not diversified you're not spread
out
number one number two it's privately
hell
which means two things uh we have no
idea what's gonna happen
right
none whatsoever it's a small operation
or it's a big operation but either way
you have very little transparency you
have very little control
uh
and you have very little liquidity once
you own it it's hard to get out of it a
lot of times
and so uh even if i was going to buy
single stocks i wouldn't buy that one
yeah the only reason i was concerned
about it was so we do have two uh roth
iras one i have one my wife has one
we've maxed out the last two years
and then
yeah i was talking to some friends and
they're saying you know even if you buy
five thousand of them at five thousand
dollars
over the course of
your entire investments
for retirement
yeah i mean it's a risk right um so i'm
not sure if that 5000 would be a risk or
if i should throw a thousand in it and
then if they go public
um the rate of return could be could be
very lucrative right yeah and you could
set a thousand dollars in the middle of
the floor and set it on fire
yeah
that's the thing about instagram man is
they like you'll see these things roll
up every once in a while if you had
invested in tesla nine years ago you
would have a hundred billion dollar what
that what that kind of thinking doesn't
tell you is how many people
sat at their friend's brother's table
with this new business idea that they
invested and they lost everything they
lost one thousand five thousand ten
thousand or whatever
um there's way more of those than there
are of the teslas in the world
you know and um so here's the thing
about this situation okay
one of two things is going to happen
you're going to make a lot of money
or you're going to lose all your money
there's probably no in between
you're either going to put 5000 in and
get 25 000 out
or you're gonna put 5000 in and say bye
um you're newly married you're trying to
buy a house
you don't need to put 5 000 on the
roulette table and hope it hits red
and that's what you're doing
so um you can do whatever you want
i've done it i did it when i was your
age and i lost it
several times
because i'm stupid and i have to learn
these lessons more than once but because
i always think i'm a glass half full guy
i always think it's going to work out oh
that's that's me and you know and it
doesn't so it's a bad investment
strategy jack i wouldn't do it and your
friends that are giving you advice on
this are people who are broke they're
not millionaires
so millionaires do steady predictable
investing they get out of debt and they
stay out of debt nothing in this
discussion falls in those under those
headings i wouldn't do it but you do
whatever you want we'll still be friends
ronald is with us in greenville north
carolina hi ronald what's up
hey dave uh this is a great day to get
talked to dave ramsey and john baloney
and i turned 52 today so this is
literally the icing on the cake happy
birthday to you young man
thank you sir just a couple quick
questions um so basically me and my wife
we're at about 1.5 1.4 million uh net
worth uh over the period of four or five
years
here at baby 77 i have rolled over uh
about 470 000 into a roth good sitting
there
um i've got about 80 000 left
before i can completely be
all of the pretax stuff has rolled over
over into the roth good number one is
that smart to do
the number two piece
is basically
being 52
do i continue to because in our job we
don't have a uh roth ira we just have a
simple outrage so would it be smart
right up to 60 years old to roll over
every year convert it and then pay the
taxes until 60 and stop at 60 doing that
you're gonna leave it alone whatever the
piece of money we're talking about if
you're not gonna touch it for ten years
it's gonna be smart
okay
even past 60.
i'm 62 and i'm going to do a roth this
year
okay okay so because i'm not gonna touch
that money i'm gonna let it grow
tax-free now if i'm gonna get the money
out sooner it starts to be questionable
as to whether that's the right direction
but uh okay but but if you're gonna
leave a long decade you're you're better
off to have the tax free growth and
let's repeat you're 100 debt free baby
step 7 house and everything you have a
wonderful a million dollar plus net
worth your baby steps millionaire you
did it on your own you didn't inherit it
it's all sitting there you've got the
cash to pay the taxes
that these that this 80 000 going from
traditional to roth creates and now that
80 000 is growing from this point tax
free
and so if it grows 10 it grows 8 000
next year that's two thousand dollars it
would have been taxable on that eight
thousand dollars is not taxable
okay and the next year and also the next
year and the next year in the next year
and also too that's smart like right now
i know with the you know
the the funds and mutual funds are down
so basically um great time to do a role
over time
and that's that's kind of what i've
looked at it and i i didn't know i was
like so again you said pretty much at 60
or passes as long as you don't touch it
with a 10-year time period continue to
do it and you got an investing horizon
of 10 years or more it's always going to
work out to do the tax-free growth
that's it it's that simple yeah and
you're doing baby step 7. now i'm not
going to tell people that have debt to
create a tax burden by rolling to a roth
while they need to be paying off their
car debt no no no no no this guy's a
baby step seven he's got extra cash all
we're doing is getting tax efficient
growth on his investments that's all
we're doing this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in less than two weeks
we're kicking off the building wealth
tour and it has been incredible to see
the buzz around these
life-changing events at these events
you're going to learn the best way to
build real
lasting wealth you'll leave with
practical easy to follow plans that
actually
work
we'll be doing uh pictures and signing
books dr john deloney at my right will
be with us rachel cruz ken coleman
and
george campbell and me
this week we announced that the event in
san antonio has sold out that there were
a few tickets left for us in uh phoenix
on september the 12th sorry uh september
the 12th is also sold out so phoenix is
completely sold out both days september
12 and 13. uh sacramento november the
1st is sold out san antonio in november
the 15th is sold out and minneapolis
november the 10th the only ones getting
tickets left so if you want to come we'd
love to have you minneapolis
a few tickets left i mean like less than
hundred so it's gonna be gone very very
soon
and uh again the tickets are only 25 you
get a four pack starting at 60 bucks
bring a bunch of friends come out it's a
party it's a pep rally for your money
and your life and your mental health and
your career and we're going to talk
about all of it and
it's a good time
these events are so fun i can't wait
that's five of them we've got and all of
them are sold out by one yeah it's a
great a great fall lineup excited about
it and also there's still tickets left
to the uh october 22nd smart conference
in dallas
and they're a whole 35 dollars for an
entire day all of the ramsey
personalities plus craig groschel amy
groschel from life church will be
speaking on marriage so lots of good
stuff going on at all of this
don't miss any of it our question of the
day comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from roberto in texas
says
i've always helped my immediate family
members if they needed money and most
have paid me back but i have two
siblings that have borrowed 9 000 bucks
through the years without paying back a
cent and neither of them work
my brother has used the kidney failure
his kidney failure as an excuse for the
past 20 years and my sister has recently
been diagnosed with diabetes and is
going down the same path
i made a promise to my parents that i
would look out for my siblings but i
feel like enough is enough
how can i let them know i will no longer
come to their aid unless they pay for
their past debt
all right dave i
can i answer this and you can you can
beat up my answer
yeah or vice versa
um
making you promise your parents you take
care of them
it looks like you are contributing to
them uh
very negative health outcomes
so if i'm this young man or if he was my
brother or my friend i would tell him
forgive the debt and sit him down and
say i'm not going to give any more money
to anybody and then move on with your
life
yep
so here's the is that right yeah now
this is not a um
a proper uh
psychological
definition
and so you can shoot holes in this
but in my opinion
number one enablers that i have met
including when i have been an enabler um
and i can think of a time recently that
i did that
the lord forgive me and shoot me in the
head if i try to do that again but um
enablers when we are enablers any of us
it is when we are the nicest people in
the world
we are too nice to say no
and in the name of being nice
we get run over
like doormats and we call that being
nice we're really good at it in the
south yeah bless your heart bless your
heart bless your heart which can mean
i'm getting results your throat or it
could mean bless your heart
we don't know what it means it depends
on the tone and the context and
everything else and then you may still
may not know so um when my wife says
bless your heart i still i'm not sure
after 40 years what she means
sometimes it's sarcastic and i do
understand but well bless your heart i
know what that means okay but um
that means you are a numb but yeah
that's um but the uh uh anyway enablers
this man is a nice man that's right
number one number two
this is this part that's probably not
psychologically correct in my opinion
someone who is enabling
they always say i always hear the
language i'm helping
they want me to help i want to help
i told my parents i would take care of
them help them
be there for them
and that i think enablers have defined
help wrong
absolutely i think enablers help use
other people as tools to make themselves
feel good yeah but i mean
if you think giving a drunk a drink is
helping them you have defined help wrong
right
you've harmed
the person that's right you've
contributed to it right you've forgotten
they're participating in their crazy
butt behavior right
now i don't know about the kidney
failure i don't know about the diabetes
i don't know what's going on here i'm
not a medical doctor
uh diabetes comes from a lot of
different things obesity is one of them
sure
um and they don't work much he said in
both their cases i think so i mean i i
don't know it could be in the in the
equation here but i i'm not gonna i
can't make a prognostic prognostication
or however you say that on a prediction
on their health or or even read motive
into their health but i i can go um
these people are not sustaining their
own lives and so i am participating in
their failure by giving them money not
only are they not sustaining their own
lives but i'm watching the quality of
their life decrease and i am paying for
i'm paying for it that's right so i'm
contributing to this yeah right it's
giving a drunk a drink it's buying a
heroin addict some heroin right
i mean when you're participating in the
when you're enabling or causing or
making it easier for
their negative behavior to continue
my son lives in my basement and he won't
get a job well what if he wasn't in your
basement
oh yeah you're contributing
because a an eagle that doesn't leave
the nest is eventually known as a turkey
kick is butt out why because you're a
big old meanie and that's tough love no
because you do love him so much that you
know he will have no dignity as a 46
year old in your basement he already
doesn't have any dignity as a 26 year
old in your basement get his little butt
out
and i would reverse it i would reverse
this too roberto and say
stop using your brother and sister as a
way to reconnect with your parents
right your parents um now we just got
hochikuchi with the psychologist our
pastor they passed away stop using your
your brother and sister and give him the
money leading to what david was talking
about leading to them having challenges
stop doing that don't use your brother
and sister anymore and don't become
you're not a loan shark to your brother
and sister yeah yeah just that money
spent i would just say yeah i agree with
john on that just i call them and say
listen it's forgiven i'm not going to
give you any more because i love you
because i love you and what i will do is
i will cheer for you i'll help you i'll
coach you i'll show you how to get a job
i'll show you how to interview for a job
i'll teach you the character you need to
keep the job i'll help you with your
budget i'll help you get out of debt by
showing you how i'll pay for you to go
to financial peace university um if you
want to take a class at the community
college and to get to get that job i'll
pay for that i'll go to the doctor with
you when he explo when the doctor went
here she explains how you're gonna
navigate your health crisis and work
right we'll figure all that out i i'll
be there with you i'm i'm there for i
love you yeah i'm not cutting you off
emotionally and relationally i'm cutting
you off financially
and the only reason i'm doing that is
because i love you so much yeah
well that's tough love no honey that's
just love just love this love what
you're doing is not love enabling is not
love it's called cowardice right
uh you don't have the backbone to say no
and you're blaming your parents because
it's using people yeah don't do that
don't do that so yeah enablers are the
nicest people in the world well even
when i'm an enabler i'm that's the one
i'm my nicest i'm because you're too
wimpy
to do the conflict
to say
dude you need to get a job this stops
you're my brother yeah you freaking lazy
you need to get up get your big butt off
the couch here man or if you've got if
you've got kidney failure we need to go
get you with some services that are
going to get you the help that you need
man this isn't working yeah and what
what kind of income producing thing can
you do yeah with that because it's not
sustainable right it's not sustainable
and there's no
dignity i was about to say i'm writing
down dignity restoration this is how you
give someone the gift of dignity yeah
here's 73 books to read
that will motivate you and i'll read
them with you right
we'll do this together we'll have a
bible study together i'll pick you up
and we'll go to church
raise our hands and praise jesus and you
know let's do it look what we got to do
let's get this thing moving called life
i'm here in your corner i'm for you but
what's happening is you're becoming
bitter toward them over nine grand
forgive the nine grand forget that it's
gone you ain't getting it back number
one number two it's holding you back
from moving them forward this is the
ramsey shop
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsay to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author host of
the doctor john dolone show is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey
solutions olivia is with us with kino
piano keanu i'm sorry i knew i was gonna
mess that up welcome welcome good to
have you guys all right where do you
live wisconsin yes what part
we live in lamarra okay which is near
small town near oshkosh yes okay there
we go that's that's something a
tennessee person recognized
beautifully how much how much debt did
you pay off
all right how long did this take just
about two years whoa
good and your range of income during
that time it ranged from 55 000 to 80
000. cool and what kind of debt was the
72
it's just about everything we had cars
credit cards
and
medical it's a medical kind of normal
yeah yeah normal americans all right
what happened what woke you up two years
ago
well it kind of first started after we
got married we used most all of our
wedding money to start paying off our
debt
and then a few months later we got
pregnant and we're like this is our i've
had a moment we can't bring a child into
this world
and not have our finances in order so
that's really where we started right
from then there's something about a baby
grows you up instantly you're like oh
this just got real
how long have you i've been married
three years three years very good
we've been together for 10 years and uh
high school sweethearts
fun very fun
so um
who how'd you get connected to this
ramsay stuff the ramsey way you know i
uh i actually was watching some vloggers
and they were talking about how excited
they were that they paid off their car
and when i saw that i was like that
seems weird i'm like i couldn't imagine
having like a paid off vehicle
so
i and they do use your name this was
years ago and i was like we should try
this and at first she was like
no you know we're not it's almost weird
cause i was like we gotta cut the credit
cards up i was gun hoe on it right away
and
um
yeah that's just how we learned for me
and then as soon as i started dropping
the ramsey name around co-workers and
family they would all start kind of
giving their two cents on it ah
okay positive or negative positive
positive or negative yeah
he's a snake oil salesman stay away from
that guy yep yeah so i sell a lot of
snake oils
lots i've got it all in my hair and
everything so olivia what probably
finally brought you along
i just
really needed to realize that i was
living beyond my means i didn't need
certain things and i just needed to
focus on our main path and changing our
family tree if we were going to have a
child and bring more children into the
life so one of the most common questions
we get is
somebody married to somebody else saying
how do i get my spouse on board what did
keanu do what was the conversation that
finally happened that's you said you're
right let's do this
he just really put out an outline for me
he's really good with spreadsheets and
he explained all that to me and i'm like
you know
that sounds awesome it would be great to
be debt-free and then we can
just
give back eventually and yeah have a
great life and so he gave you a vision
of what this looks like vision
definitely gave me a great outlook on it
and i'm like yes let's do this
yeah very fun
very fun love my spreadsheets
so you how did you you heard about us
and then how did you plug into our stuff
just the youtube or what youtube and the
podcast i would listen to the podcast
every day at work and i'd come home with
something new to show her yeah we'd be
listening to the podcast all night i'd
say when it's going through everybody's
story and he's like see this could be us
when it really took off was when we
started
actually putting everything out in a
budget and first we were trying to use
like random budgeting like apps and
stuff and then we were like well we
should just use the every dollar app
that makes more sense and then we
started seeing how much money we were
wasting crazy amounts of money like this
money could easily be used
what was what were you wasting it on
going out to dinner or shopping
and
there was sometimes we were sitting
there like we have no idea where all
this money went yeah we would be so
confused like
we're living paycheck to paycheck where
is all this money coming from so once we
started putting everything down into the
budget we're like
this is where it's going we cannot do
this anymore we need to change
especially with the baby on the way yeah
yeah yeah the baby gives you that
urgency that's fine we've got to change
our family tree we got to be grown-ups
when this little one gets here we can't
children raising children not a plan
so how old are you guys now i'm 24. i'm
26. wow and you all owe nobody
nope how's it feel
feels great great
it's uh it's a weight off the shoulders
for sure um
it seemed like every week we were
getting hit with a different credit card
payment and stuff and
it just it was
it puts you in like a depressive state
at times where you're sitting there like
i'm finally getting ahead and then you
also realize oh i forgot to pay the
capital one bill this week and
now we owe an extra 75 bucks yeah
and it's just great to be able to do
this at such a young age too and we
don't have to worry about doing this in
the future
will you go back into that no
no
no you you two don't understand what
you've done for your financial future
yet
you'll be 35 and y'all will be smiling
and then you'll be 45 and you'll be
really smart like what you all have
millionaires oh my goodness i hope so
that's the plan yeah you are you will uh
no question all right when people hear
you did this and they ask how do you get
out of debt what do you tell them
i tell them that start off with a game
plan and
sit down especially if you're married or
something sit down with them
and write everything out and you work as
a team you can't work against each other
you can't hide things from each other
you need to work as a team and
just make sure everybody's on the same
page because that's the only way you win
cash is king
[Laughter]
i like it very good very good well done
all right and you brought your son with
you we did and what is his name grayson
grayson all right we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you we're proud
of you too well done you guys very proud
of you oh he's great oh look at this
cookie in hand that's how he can be
happy i love it that's fun and i also
got a copy of financial peace university
for you a one-year membership to that
and we will also send you or give you a
copy of the total money makeover you can
give that away and get somebody's
journey started so very very cool good
stuff all right keanu olivia and grayson
from wisconsin 72 000 paid off in two
years making 55 to 80. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
well done you guys very well done
so for everybody listening i hope you
heard this trajectory here
he really wanted to get out of debt he
wanted to follow his plan
wife wasn't on board so he sat down and
he painted a picture of this is what
this could look like for us and he had a
plan how to get there and he said i'll
be a part of this if you will right so
it's it's all of that stuff right have a
dream meeting yes with your spouse what
this could look like and um and paint it
out in great detail in hd this is
exactly where we could be sitting we
could be in this situation at this age
and here's because the math says we can
and it's not high it's not pie in the
sky this is conservative this is
reasonable we get out of debt then we
get the house paid off during that time
we build this level of wealth we're 35
we'll be sitting here with this kind of
net worth and um you know and puts you
in a completely different mindset then
because you start to believe it's
possible when i was about
old was i was 22 years old
and um i went to one of these uh
multi-level get-rich-quick things oh i
thought you're gonna see a covered wagon
convention yeah okay so but
yeah let me tell you what let me tell
you what they carry when they're right
on covered wagons they carry
colt 45.
so um just keep that in mind all right
so uh
[Laughter]
circle the wagons the cellones are here
all right
um but the uh uh yeah so i have no idea
what it is the multi-level marketing
convention
the multi-level so anyway the guys pops
up there a uh a compound interest chart
and says if you saved a hundred dollars
a month at 12
uh for from age 30 to age 60 h25 to 65
you'd have 1 million 176 thousand
dollars
and i went
why didn't everybody do that
right right
because i was 22. yeah and i'm like i
don't even have to get started though
i'm 25. yeah 25 to 65 40 years
at 100 a month 12 percent
1 million 176 thousand dollars you can't
get 12
it wasn't the point the point was why
didn't everybody do that yeah because
once you see the math it gives you a
vision and you go dadgum
everybody a hundred dollars a month
everybody ought to be a millionaire
[Music]
that's just crazy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
glad you're here dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host
thanks for hanging out with us tom's
with us in lima ohio hi tom welcome to
the ramsay show
hey guys it's really nice to speak to
both of you you too what's up
hey i was wondering a little dispute
between my fiance and i yes
that's what we're here for
yeah we're getting married in 16 days
i'm 20 she's 21.
you lose whatever the dispute is you
lose
uh it's not much just a very slight uh
disagreement i guess okay um that's how
i can tell you're not married there is
no slight disagreement but go ahead no
all right yeah
i was going to wait till i was in person
whenever we come down during our
honeymoon but
i found a truck sooner than later
we're closing on selling our house we're
moving to
we're going to rent my grandparents
family farm with the plans of buying it
in three to five years
but anyways we have about a hundred and
two thousand in equity
on our house
that we'll be getting a check for
tomorrow
and then we're wanting to uh get a
little bit nicer truck than we have now
what do you have now
i have a 2002 chevy with 170 000 miles
okay pretty rough and what do you make a
year
um between the two of us it's going to
be around 85 to 90. okay and what are
you talking about spending on a truck
i found a really nice 2017 f-350 for 37
000. so it'd be around 40 000 after
taxing title
nope
she wins
all right
yeah you're going to spend half your
income on a truck
okay you don't want to have more than
half here and you don't have more than
half your income tied up in things that
are going down in value and by the time
we buy her a car you've got more than
half your annual income tied up and
things going down in value you do need a
better truck but you went whole hog here
you need to back off a notch or three
yeah like 10 grand
10 grand is 10 times nicer than what you
got 10 grand is 10 times nicer than what
you got
yeah
he doesn't sound enthused sorry man
you called a couple of dudes on a radio
show and you're like these guys will be
uh we just ruined i'm sorry yeah
hey you got a lot going on you're you
sold a house you're getting married and
you're moving all in less than a month
yeah it's okay if you wait to buy a
truck a little bit
yeah
okay yeah and and i i
you know
you have you have too many things too
many balls in the air you're gonna drop
one and that was one you were getting
ready to drop you i i wouldn't do it i
wouldn't do it and you asked us and
because i want you to have a i want you
to be able to pay cash for this farm
more than i want you to have that truck
yeah i'd love to be able to put at least
30 or 40 percent down on the farm yeah
and the cheaper truck you buy the more
likely that is and the funnest part
about having a farm is all the gear
right
like i can't just have an f-150 or an
f-250 you have to have an f3 right it
just it just you can gear yourself out
of a lot of money man
no stop it john
i know i like the toys man but i don't
know
no it's uh
here's the thing
things that have motors and have wheels
whatever they are they go down in value
like 99 of them do
and if you're going to build wealth you
minimize the things that you buy that go
down in value you maximize the things
that you bound to go up in value fairly
simple equation
but if you you know like
here's another one tom and john will
relate to this i was driving the other
day i cut through a back way and i got
over into this uh new little
neighborhood and it was a little um it
was nice
nice homes but they were starter home
maybe one half notch above a starter
home okay kind of slammed all together
and you know the little driveways are
coming down the front they're all kind
of it looks like a um truman show or
something right
they ran through and just buzzed the
trees down and just threw them out yeah
it's just a it's just it's a subdivision
you know kind of classic right but nice
they were nice they were it wasn't
trashy
but they weren't mansions they weren't
even mcmansions okay
and but what struck me was
as i drove along there that most of the
cars were not in the garages they were
in the driveways in front of the garage
or in the street in front of the house
because they wouldn't fit in there and
as i'm driving along there i can look
and i'm adding up the price of the two
cars sitting in front of that house and
i go dude
if you weren't driving those two you
wouldn't be in that house yep
dude if you weren't driving those two
you wouldn't be in that house and so you
can tell these people have got their
thing bass backwards that's right that's
right and they've got all their money in
wheels
rather than in real estate they've got
their money in image right yeah well
yeah i mean because the people at the
stoplight need to be impressed exactly
you will never meet them but they need
to be impressed with the people that
walk by the parking lot where your car's
parked for eight hours of its day yeah
and they're really going to be moved by
that car you've got you know i mean i i
you know i uh
the first time i heard this really
pissed me off i had i was making good
money it was a real estate business
before i went broke and i bought a
jaguar
and i thought man i'm a cop so bad i got
a jaguar i'm the coolest dude on the
planet
and my grandpa who worked 38 years as a
cost accountant at alcoa i went down to
see him now he had a um a 68
i wish i had this truck
a 68 short bed chevy lime green
three on the tree yeah
oh
and it was perfect
and um i gum come wheeling up and he had
about probably a million two in money
markets cash never invested a thing
because he's a child of the depression
right just just stacked cash that's all
he did and i knew he had money but i
didn't know how much till he died but um
i rolled up in that thing with my cool
suit with the little pocket thing in it
you know looked like ken coleman right
yeah and
man i i i come rolling out of that
jaguar and he comes out and he looks he
goes what is that
i said it's a jaguar and he goes what in
the world
i said well it's a european vehicle
grandpa it'll
it's it's kind of fancy and he goes oh
it looks like it he goes what that thing
cost i told him he goes he whistled he
said
that's dumber than a rock
[Laughter]
and i said well what do you mean you
insulted me i thought i was cool i was
there for my grandpa to brag on me and
he that's dumber than a rock
and i said what do you mean he goes well
you take that amount of money and you
put it in a savings account you know how
much you'll be in there in 10 years and
i said how much he told me just
ran that calculator right
and i said um he said you know what that
car is going to be worth in 10 years i
said well it holds its value he said no
it doesn't
that's that's a lie people tell
themselves to buy crap like this
oh so mad i was mad for six weeks yeah i
mean i wasn't just mad for six minutes i
just left i mean i wasn't mad at him i
was just mad because he was right he's
right that's right you know and it it
didn't you know it just had boiled me
boiled me because i was there i had a
whole different image a whole different
thing set up and of course i had
borrowed every dime i didn't 100
financed yeah you know and uh uh
man but you know that's one of those
lessons you just don't you don't get to
quote drive away from you know
smart people put the money in things
that go up in value dumb people put
money and things go down in value and
you need to buy some things that are
nice of course they have wheels i've got
nice cars but but they're a small
percentage of my net worth and of my
income i and i i identify with this
young man
because
it's a truck we're a couple of months
out from me finally replacing my old
truck when you need it too your old
truck was a piece of crap it's not great
i still got it i got a couple more
months i'm not there yet look at you
kicking me while i'm down yeah um but i
also oh the covered wagon jokes gonna
come back to haunt you
uh but hey i i understand i'm a couple
months out and i understand like all
just pull up i was just looking on
websites before the show started and
thought i bet i could i could pull the
trigger on the nope just follow the plan
man just follow the plan
take a breath calm down you're 20. wait
three more months it's time you're gonna
be married in 16 days
good idea to start marriage with her
being right yes
yes so because it will end with her
being right good idea that's gonna you
might as well start that way because
it's working it's coming in yeah
yeah i get man i get it man you want a
new truck you need a truck it's all good
all joking about wives and stuff aside
but here's the thing
who can find a virtuous wife the proverb
says
for her worth is far above rubies the
heart of her husband safely trusts her
and he will have no lack of gain
now his wife is not a nag she's not a
jerk his wife to be she just has
swizzles she's wise yeah and she just
said this is a smart yep and he's like
me he's a little boy on the serial aisle
but i want one i want one and uh then he
called this show and we said no she's
right my brother no
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where dead is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host thank you for joining us america
open phones at
we 825-5225 people build wealth do work
they love and create actual amazing
relationships dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today thanks for
joining us america
so uh jerome powell of the fed
is ready to
bring some pain
to households and businesses quote
unquote
these are the unfortunate costs
of reducing inflation
powell said that the market will have to
weaken before inflation be can be
considered under control and these are
the unfortunate
costs of reducing inflation a failure to
restore price stability would mean
greater far greater pain
um but let's roll this up though he's
talking about what the sentence before
he says the u.s labor market why does
the labor market have to go south for
the economy to recover
while higher interest rates slower
growth and softer labor market
conditions will bring down inflation
they will also bring some pain to
households and businesses
brought to you by your government
okay
now here's what's interesting um
god this is so
infuriating
um
the problem is he's wrong
that's the other problem not only is he
is this just
so
much an
aristocracy that talks down their nose
to regular people and i'm going to throw
the switch over here and you poor people
are going to have some pain in your
households and businesses but you're
going to like it but you're going to
like me for it yeah
because it gets rid of inflation
you
arrogant
yeah
yeah
andy's wrong
it's um
okay so where did this inflation come
from inflation increase in prices okay
we've talked about this on the show
before but let's talk about it again
inflation in this case did not come from
a white-hot economy
that the economy just grew and grew and
was too much prosperity god help us
to the point that prices started
shooting up because there was just too
much good things going on so prices just
go up now that actually happened in the
70s
okay that was real inflation in that
sense the inflation that we had was what
we're calling inflation and it is
inflation it's an increase in prices
was primarily caused by a couple of
things
when you
don't produce goods and services
for a half a year or a year
you create a shortage of those goods and
services
you create a shortage of lumber you
create a shortage of automobiles you
create a shortage of
almost everything
when you create a shortage of something
100 of the time the prices go up did you
notice toilet paper
you know you create a shortage of it you
create this this
ridiculous urgency to buy
people came out of their houses after
covet and they've been sitting around
looking at their own
grimy house and they said i don't live
in a grimy house anymore i'm going to
buy another house
and they rushed out of their homes like
coming out of the caves like a baptist
after a casserole and went crazy buying
houses and drove house prices up demand
was ridiculous and we saw one of the
highest increases in house prices in a
single year almost ever
in 2020
and i was 20 29 it went up wow house
price went up shortage more buyers than
sellers
scarcity
it's a supply demand curve they used to
teach it in the seventh grade i don't
think they teach it anymore apparently
they didn't teach it to jerome
so um
but that's what you know drove prices up
it was not a white hot economy it was a
shortage created by
a
fouchy induced quarantine
where we shut everything down you
remember when we had to flatten the
curve or we were all going to die it's
just just for dinner anybody ever come
back and go that was a bunch of bull
crap just for two weeks anybody ever
come back and call bs on that but they
never did but let's just go ahead and
remember we had to flatten the curve
where we were all going to die right and
so they shut the factories down
and you remember then when you had to be
six feet apart but then you didn't
and you remember then when you had to
buy a mask and but they didn't you
remember then if you got vaccine you
wouldn't get coveted but then you got
covered anyway you remember all that
stuff this all affected the economy
because people weren't working in
producing goods and services creating a
shortage and that shortage drove prices
up it's pent up demand right exactly
exactly
and so lumber went 3x yeah
and on top of that then you reach over
here to the biden administration and
they say well everybody needs to be
driving electric cars because that's
good for the air quality even though we
know that fossil fuels actually create
the electricity that goes into the car
so it's kind of a problem there but
anyway we're still going to cut off the
fuel
spike it and create a shortage on gas so
now we got five dollar gas at the pump
brought to you by a green policy in the
white house
okay so
inflation at the pump inflation in
housing inflation in
uh supply chain disruptions that's
creating shortages ships and all that
stuff so
interest rates being low
did not cost this inflation
shortages cost it
we just established that
so interest rates being high
does not fix this inflation it's
exacerbated and suffering to you little
people because that's what you deserve
because you're inflationary people
thank you jerome you arrogant no good
bureaucrat
so i mean seriously
if in if low interest rates did not heat
up the economy and cause this inflation
then it is fairly easy to establish that
high interest rates are not going to
slow down the economy in the way you
want it to the way you slow down the
economy is you get the supply chain
working again and you turn the stupid
green off at the white house and get the
pipeline flowing again and if they
flooded the cert then prices would go
down because there'd be a surplus of
lumber and a service of gasoline bricks
and workers you know what gas was two
dollars under trump it's not because
trump's a magician
because all he did was say drill baby
drill yeah that's all he said
it's the exact opposite and there's a
there's a glut a an over supply of
gasoline well i remember that day there
was one day that prices went down
it went under two dollars and oil went
negative oil went negative everyone went
negative but gas at the pump was under
two dollars yeah does anybody that was
20 minutes ago y'all not remember this
and and no trump can't he'll strut
around take credit for it but he didn't
do it right it was just he let chevron
do their job let exxon do their job
their job is not woke virtue signaling
their job is drill for all right that's
their job
and they're good at their job by the way
they can produce the crap out of it if
you leave them alone
so it so the way you fix inflation when
there's shortages is you help the
companies not you help the companies
under production
not not raise interest rates but these
bozos are raising interest rates and
they're going to slow down the economy
but they're going to slow it down in
ways they don't want to slow it down and
then it's going to be hard to jump start
it again seems like they're going crazy
it's just going to it's just no it's not
going to create a crash it's just dumber
than crap it's classic keynesian
economic socialism and these guys
tinkering mad men tinkering with the
sound board and buddy they got the sound
all off
and arrogant
you arrogant
they will also bring some pain to
households and businesses
that's your fed talking to you people
america they need their butts fired if
anybody worked for me and acted like
that i'd fire them
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host in case you haven't heard the
news we're in a recession the stock
market's falling inflation's out of
control we're all gonna die
okay calm down uh if you're investing
this is not time to panic
fear is not your friend
calm down breathe breathe facts are your
friends dr john delaney says it all the
time
you guys stay level-headed the only
person gets hurt on a roller coaster if
you're investing are those that jump off
in the middle of the ride ride ride red
red ray don't jump off in the doom and
the gloom turn off your television
history shows us that the economy
recovers time and time again
it's happened every time there's been a
dip there's always a it always comes up
and you may miss the coming up if you
jump out at the dip that's how this
works so if you need help in finding an
investing pro someone who can guide you
through all of this someone can talk you
out of your tree
and we all need those check out our
smart investor program it's an easy way
to find pros who truly serve with
excellence they'll be there to help you
figure out what's best for you stay
focused on your long-term goals and to
get connected with up to five smart mr
pros in your area go to
ramseysolutions.com smart vester you can
talk with the pros pick the one you want
to work with and make an investing plan
you feel confident with that's
ramseysolutions.com
so we'll just throw in with that
particular mention about smartvestor
john that um
lots of research tracking the actual
statistics of the stock market
the people who try to time the market
100 of the time do not get the
performance of the people who just get
in the market and stay yeah
and so what we then find is that people
who buy mutual funds on their own
for instance i buy some no load no
commission mutual funds
and i buy some mutual funds through my
smartvisor pro
but if you do not have an advisor if you
only buy no loads and you are there
subject to your own self as your own
self telling your own self what to do
all the time
you will have more of a tendency to jump
in and jump out and attempt to time the
market usually in fear rather than greed
but sometimes in greed rather than fear
and in either one of those cases do you
end up out performing the market
so what we also find in the research is
is the people that have a good
investment professional who's got a
steady hand at the wheel
not some
slime ball but somebody's got a steady
hand at the wheel he talks you off the
ledge and talks you out of being greedy
talks you out of being afraid and stick
with it be boring be the tortoise don't
be the hair be boring be the tortoise
don't be the hair and they say that to
you a thousand times over 20 years and
you never jump in and you never jump out
because of that investment professional
you make more money that's right not
even because of they advised you on some
trick stock scheme they just
just
made you stay in yeah they just talked
you into staying in yeah and that's all
they did and if that's all they do
they're worth their money yep
because people that don't have one have
a higher tendency to jump out
and it's pretty simple
you people that you you know you stay
invested the number of times i have sold
out of the market
because of
economic situation is precisely zero
never and i've been investing for 40
years yeah
but once i got that dialed in in my head
i have not broken that and i've not
thrown money into the market when it was
down out of greed trying to time it
i almost did once yeah
in 2008 and i would have been in 2009. i
would have been so right i would have
caught it right at the bottom but um
but i didn't i just said that's not my
policy it's not my principle is just
steady principles not try to figure it
out catch it at the bottom catch it at
the top principles just keep going
and that works every time jeremy's in
jackson tennessee jeremy how are you
doing well how are you mr dave better
than we deserve sir how can we help
uh so i am
trying to
get rid of a massive amount of debt uh
on a vehicle it's approximately seventy
five thousand dollars 000
and i am
yes and i am 22 000 under
uh under trade in value
what kind of car is how much i would it
is a truck
um it is a 2021
dodge ram
and it was a
[Music]
false need that my wife and i felt we
needed whenever we were getting ready to
move
we thought we needed a truck in order to
save money on a u-haul and
moving companies
um
so now that's incredible
we're trying yeah now that we're trying
to
do the the baby steps and get a hold of
our our debt
i understand that this truck needs to be
to be gone what do you guys think of
here
our take home our net take home is
approximately 105.
holy gramoli
you owe 75 000 on a dodge pickup
yes okay and you looked up the trade-in
value on kelly blue book
yes and you got 50 000 bucks
yes did you talk to a dealer
not yet no um
that's my next step is to go in and talk
to a dealer did you trade a negative
equity into this thing
yes oh okay all right
yes it was
it was 2021 it wouldn't have gone down
25 000 yet no
you'd probably make money off of it yeah
it was a
it was a very
poor decision yeah
that's an understanding that one that
obviously should have never happened
that's an understatement yeah and yeah
when you trade a 75 000
vehicle for a u-haul rental you you
really
you really struggled you're really
struggling with math on that one yeah
yeah so um okay
wow
oh man i'm so sorry how old are you
i am 26 as is my wife okay you have any
money i know i guess not
no money
uh no sir no sir
like none saved yet
is this a hemi
uh yes yeah
okay
and you are in jackson tennessee
okay um so here's what you need to do
first is you need to learn
a lot about the dodge hemi truck market
i don't know a lot about it
but the the truck market in general is
way up and it's not as up as far as it
was a few months ago
uh and because of the electric car craze
and the threatening of doing away with
nice big engines and trucks uh stuff
like the hemi i have an unusually good
popularity
because those of us that are rednecks
that burn gas we want a big old honking
gas engine and that one is
okay
so the good news is you kind of got a
cult truck you got a truck that a
certain segment of the population thinks
is unbelievably cool
you follow me so i i want you to poke
around and find that nuanced segment of
the population and let's figure out what
they are paying
for a dodge with a hemi in it
um
so the um
let's pretend
that you could get
62 for it
okay
which i'm gonna guess and say it might
take four or five months of poking
around learning about where to sell it
how to sell it but that might be full
boat retail on the thing
what'd you pay for it
actual sticker at the time
i think it was
68
or 69 it's a 21 you said right
yes sir how many miles
uh it's currently got
eight eighty two hundred did you have
you torn it up
no okay do not run it through the brush
treat it like it's a mercedes okay
because you got to keep it in pristine
condition to sell it like new i like new
21 that it was stickered at 68. you
might get 62. i might be right i was
yeah you're not going to fall off i'm
impressed at how good i am at this
so i'm thinking you're going to do that
okay but you're still
14 15 000 bucks in the hole you're 26
years old and you're broke so you're
still going to have to go down the
credit union and borrow
fifteen thousand bucks and buy a three
thousand dollar car
or two thousand dollar car for cash
right and you're on fifteen thousand
dollars that and the fifteen thousand
dollars the amount of money you lose on
this truck
i want you to write it down i want you
to take a picture standing beside the
truck right on the back of the picture
print the picture out and keep it in
your file
i used to do this stuff i've done a lot
of stupid things and when i lose money
on something i call it stupid tax
and my young friend you were about to
pay some stupid tax because you were
straight up stupid when you did this
and so you want to remember it so you
never do it again
you can get out of this and we'll help
you
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage cameron
and maddie are with us hey guys how are
you hey we're good how are you dave
welcome welcome where do you all live
uh cincinnati ohio cool welcome to
nashville how much that have you paid
off
so we paid off 227 thousand and three
hundred dollars in uh roughly 30 months
a lot wow
that's a lot of money well done how long
and what was your range of income during
that two and a half years so when we
started out it was around 80 000 and uh
wrapping up it was 220 000. nice job
what do y'all do for a living
for nurses both of us are nurses
yeah so how do you go from 80 to 20 as
nurses good question so we're both
nurses by trade but i transitioned
actually into the medical device
industry um shortly after my nursing
career yeah
okay and uh doing very well at that
apparently
it's going well yeah we did in the in
the middle there we did a travel
assignment together so that really took
care of the grand majority of that debt
um but yeah we worked our butts off
right very cool very cool good for you
what kind of debt was the 227 so uh
boatload of student loans
nursing school yes uh four degrees worth
of student loans actually and uh then uh
two cars two cars are paid off all right
how long you been married
home four years now four
years year and a half into marriage we
kind of say okay wait a minute now we
got to do like the adult part of this
what happened what was the wake-up call
yeah so in the beginning of marriage we
went through a lot of premarital
counseling and um we knew that one of
the biggest reasons why people get
divorced is money problems and so
we definitely started dabbling in in
your content we watched a lot of youtube
a lot of podcasts and we had good
mentors in our church we met at church
so we had a really good relationships
and i think at some point you know in
the beginning of our marriage i was
still in school and so we were living on
a very small amount of income at that
time it was just cameron's income and so
we kind of dabbled in paying off our
debt but we didn't get really serious
until about you know eight nine months
in and then like once we got into it it
was so overwhelming for us because we
had such a big number and i don't even
really think we factored our cars in at
that point we were just looking at the
student loans like how did we rack up we
do
almost 200 grand in student loan debt
and looking at the interest we were like
if we don't pay this off now we're going
to pay double what it is
and it really was my husband that led
the charge on it i'm i'm the spender
he's the saver
um but i'm also the risk taker so i
think i think we make a good pair yeah
so what what caused you to be able to
kind of double down and say all right
this ramsay process we're going to use
it
when when did that really kick into gear
yeah i would say
um
when we first got married i always had
that uneasy feeling of i just felt like
when i was going to work i was like i
just felt like we were
paying everything we were receiving
we're like it's not ours you know so i
kept reminding us like you know we're in
all this debt
let's just keep thinking of those keep
the y in mind and keep
that the main thing and that feeling of
hey when we're when we're out of this
debt all the money we're making is ours
we don't have to give it to our lender
we're enslaved to our lender so i think
we just kept the y the main thing and uh
and i think once i started working and
we had dual income we were like okay now
we can really make this happen and
you know accelerate our our debt free
journey and i think once we got to a
point where we were
under a hundred thousand like we just
went crazy but people thought we were
insane like we were making massive
payments every month and saying no to
everything yeah it was baby step baby
step sprint yeah just get use the
momentum yeah most people don't
recognize how challenging it is to be a
young married couple
or newlyweds figuring this stuff out on
top of the additional pressure where
your colleagues kind of have a ballpark
of what you're making and why are you
driving that and why are you bringing
your own lunch how did y'all navigate
being married and finding your own
identity with other people saying what
are you doing
yeah good question i think we had a
really good community of you know
believers who knew the why behind what
we were doing
um and i think a lot of people really
admired it i think some people that i
worked with thought i was crazy um but
it was inspiring once we could you know
send out that final photo of us paying
off our debt i got hundreds of messages
of people asking like how did you do it
help me um what do you tell them what do
you tell them how you did it oh i always
give credit to you
oh thank you thank you
i mean what are the principles to get
out of that
so the
the biggest principle i think that
really changed everything for us was
knowing where our money was going i
think having a budget and every month
tracking everything that you spend we
use every dollar
and i used to get in the beginning of
the journey i really um i hated that end
of the month meeting where we were
looking at every dollar because my
husband would be like all right what is
this ten dollars on amazon and i'm like
it's ten dollars
yeah yeah we we grew a lot but he would
always tell me like that's not our ten
dollars it's not ours like you know so i
think budgeting was massive for us and
then realizing that and we watched a lot
of your videos and talking to people
like we had to have the realization
we're broke like we make a decent income
but really we're broke we have a
negative net worth so we have to live
like we're broke and we did
yeah yeah that's that is kind of a
switch that flips that's it but it's an
incredible amount of wisdom for somebody
to get there right and as nurses you
both have those hard conversations or
you're in the room when those hard
conversations this is the reality that
we face and for somebody to get there
that's the magic moment so good for
y'all just to look them here and say
yeah we make a lot of money it's not
ours i love i've never heard that i love
that that's not our money and we're
broke and we make 100 we're broke
here's what we have to do to get out of
this that's that's incredible yeah yeah
and it can be overwhelming at first you
know it's just start small start getting
the momentum keep your why in mind keep
that that vision at the end that you can
live and give like no one else and just
take the momentum and run with it yeah
and now we feel so free yeah no we're
not the shackles yes
we're free well congratulations very
very well done all right when you look
back on it it's 30 months really really
tough
what was the hardest
part of the whole thing
you want to take that first
yeah we were just talking about that i
think because of the principles we
learned it was like we're like
it's honestly because we we it kind of
taught us a lot of things about
materials and um it kind of taught us
like less stuff less stress you know
like yeah
so for us it wasn't the material aspect
i think it was just that the discipline
it took and you know the rollercoaster
of emotions and and i think our marriage
i think we had to learn how to
communicate really well with each other
and realize we're on the same team i
think a lot of times
having different spending habits we
yeah we argued about how we should spend
money and what was significant
yeah no i'm not kidding
i'm not exaggerating
and you know i think at some point we
had to be like okay we're on the same
team and like here's the vision let's
write it down
and give glory to god and do this for
our future and our family tree and i
think now i look back on the student
loan forgiveness program and things like
that and it's easy to get bitter and be
like we just paid off our debt and we
could have used that but i think i would
go back and do it all over again because
we have the character traits and like
the hard one wisdom
and you got the calluses so much more
valuable and we're different people now
right like we are we're different people
will you ever borrow money again never
absolutely not never again never again
very cool
well congratulations you guys we're very
proud of you excellent job got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
and a financial peace university one
year subscription and a total money
makeover book read all that stuff do all
that stuff give it all away whatever you
want to do we we're proud of you we just
want to say thanks for coming to
nashville and letting us be part of your
celebration oh thank you guys thanks for
watching we've changed our lives thank
you so much cameron and maddie
cincinnati ohio 227 000 paid off in 30
months making 80 to 220
knocked it out baby count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three two one we're done
[Applause]
that's how it's done
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 10 10 the
thief comes only to steal and kill and
destroy
i have come that they may have life and
have it to the full
john eldridge said don't ask yourself
what the world needs ask yourself what
makes you come alive because what the
world needs are men who have come alive
absolutely
absolutely open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five now
john we're going to have to get with
rachel and george
with their teslas
their plug-in cars
um
that are
saving the environment hey i love them
by using uh by using electricity created
by fossil fuels
we know this because officials peter
hassan just tweeted officials will ask
californians not to charge
electric vehicles if conditions worsen
there's
rolling blackouts and an electricity
shortage california because of course
fossil fuels there's a shortage of right
now because uh they're evil and they've
been cut off
and uh we're creating a problem with
electricity uh we also have seen
electricity nationwide go up 15
percent why is that
because there's a shortage of fossil
fuels and most electricity is created by
fossil fuels
oh
so your your emissions-free car that's
electric
by definition is not
emissions-free it's just creating the
admission somewhere else well the
emissions had to be done to create the
fuel that went into your car the
electricity your car didn't create
emissions but lots of emissions were
created to create electricity to go into
your car
so just to help you with this it's
something you need to think about that's
um
this uh i'm saving the planet
bull crap
you're just moving
you just move the end of the tailpipe
over to the factories instead of the
vacuum car that's all that's all you did
i didn't know that
this message comes after california
regulators moved last week to require
all new vehicles in the state to run on
electricity by 2035 and now they're
going to ask californians not to charge
electric vehicles if conditions worsen
so um
kind of that kind of sounds like a
problem we're going to uh
it's on september 1 we're going to
wave some of your uh student loans
and then
september 2nd
we're going to sign up for that new
semester we're going to let you take out
some more loans
kind of the same thing gosh man it's a
logical government here's the thing when
i was a kid
um i grew up in houston and hurricanes
would come through and it would knock
trees over
and when you wake up in the morning you
go just survey the damage it was just it
was a scary time right and
nobody had any time for
all of the complaining and what you just
got to move the trees like let's get to
the root of this issue so that we can
drive down these roads and there's what
we have to do and nobody
will get to the root of some of these
actual issues man and it's just a bunch
of people
intervening in like you mentioned
earlier intervention after intervention
and the more interventions man the more
a system just falls over on itself
without dealing with the root man yep
instead of letting the natural flow
occur on these things jennifer is in
kansas city hi jennifer how are you
i'm good thank you
good how can we help 59 years old
and um i am single
i am currently renting and i want to
know in
based on my age
and the current environment should i
continue to rent or should i buy
okay
let me ask you a funny question
yeah when you gonna die
[Laughter]
because if we know that we can tell you
what to do
not today jennifer
later uh how's your health
uh decent yes i'm okay you said you're
68 or 69 right
i'm i'm getting ready to turn 69. yeah
and um
so how long did your parents live
uh my dad's 73
um and my mom 92 okay
uh you think you're on your mom's track
i would
no no
well
it's hard to tell how's your house
detail your health is good you said
right right now my health is good yeah
the only reason not to believe that
there's no indicators that you're not
going to live 10 years
today oh no no that'd be 89.
no it'd be 79. yeah okay
yeah but either way so here's the thing
if you're gonna live five years or more
you're gonna be better off to own
okay and i think you are
we don't know obviously can we just
speak that into a joke
i'm 62 so i'm just a little bit younger
than you but i mean we're joking around
about that you know
right but um
but mathematically
the house will go up in value you're
going to stabilize the largest expense
in your budget which is housing
because guess what rent does every year
no matter what it goes up yeah and for
10 years more it's going to go up every
year for it's going to go up 10 times
you buy a house now your house payments
are not ever going to go up
how do you approach
the amount that you leave in your
investments versus the amount that you
put down on on a home how much do you
have in investments
i have 575 is my net worth
good good for you
and um
what what do you pay in rent today what
do you live in today
uh one bedroom i pay 12.50 okay what
could you buy something like that for
like a one bedroom condo or a small
two-bedroom condo right
yeah i i ca i can find a small like
two-bedroom
house or a two-bedroom condo for that
yes for how much i mean how much total
price
[Music]
well it depends on if there's a
homeowner association a fee or not i'm
just saying the price what would your
sales price be the purchase price be
250
sounds high
okay okay if i could get you into
something for 150 175 i'm probably doing
it in cash write a check in cash and be
done with it
if i can get you in there for 200 maybe
even 250 that's starting to be half of
your nest egg i'm starting a little
scared then
okay gotcha you see how i'm doing that
yeah but i want you to pay cash for it
not only payments
oh okay
so let's pretend okay let's let's walk
this through let's say you bought a
property for 200 000 you said you had
575 that'd be 375 correct
correct all right and uh if it's
invested in good growth stock mutual
funds and if it averages 10 it'll double
every seven years so you're 68 at 75 the
375 will be um
750 be 800 almost right
just under 800 800 000
about 750 000 whatever and so um
if it's uh we'll call it let's call it
700 000 so just call it conservative
seven more years at 82 you'd have 1.4
million
if you're not living out of it are you
living on uh pension and social security
and not touching their retirement right
now
no i have to take money out of
retirement how much do you take how much
do you take out
currently i'm taking out about um three
thousand
um so thirty six thousand thirty six
thousand dollars a year
yeah okay
but your rent is 12.50
correct yeah you wouldn't have that
anymore
right
okay okay so
uh my point is you're gonna use some of
this money but the money will double
roughly every seven years that you leave
in there
okay and so if we do this at and we just
said you're gonna have seven hundred
thousand dollars cash a two hundred
thousand dollar house it's gone up a
bunch in seven years and you have no
payments all in the meantime we've
stabilized your most expensive
your most expensive part of your life
which is housing
we cut we got rid of the cost and we
stabilized it now your insurance and
taxes and hoa fees will probably change
but they're minor compared to rent
or payments
so i would have a budget around 200 and
i'd start looking there's no rush
nothing's on fire take your time
go get a bargain on something do a
little work to it if you want to or
something like that
but but find you a deal at 200 that's a
nice condo or a small home
and
that's what i would do
i pay cash for it and you've done a
really good job by the way yeah
congratulations yeah by the time you're
75 you're going to be a millionaire
that's pretty interesting to think about
good work good work john thanks for
hanging out with me today you bet thank
you that puts us out of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you